no relaxing though when you have a kid
as talented as ian anderson facing you
for the atlanta braves anderson two and
one on the year makes his seventh start
and coming off a four run four inning
performance last time out against the
blue jays down in dunedin florida
anderson's facing the phillies for the
third time this year he's given up four
homers the phillies are the only team
that's taking him deep and the first
pitch to jeans sagura is lying deep down
the left field line and hooked
did he hit a home run i think he thinks
it's uh out and he
jean segura has a home run how about
that we never even saw it leave the yard
down in the corner
and uh gene segura hits a laser on the
first pitch i mean right down the left
field line
and looking at it again that thing hit
over the wall into the bullpen and
bounced back onto the field of play he
got a hanger and it's one nothing
phillies how about that how about that
jt romuto climb into the right-hand
batter's box with one on and one out
here's jt romuto and he shoots one to
the gap and right center field it's
pretty deep and that one's gonna bang
off the 16-foot high brick wall harper
on his way to third the throw to second
he's just in there safely alec ball he's
been one of their best rbi men in his
young career three and one the count
anderson's pitch swung on ground the
ball the other way towards second it'll
get a run home as aubi's up with it
he'll throw to first and bowm picks up
the rbi as harper scores and it's two to
nothing phillies vince velasquez 1-0
with a 4-9-1 era going six innings
giving up
four hits to the brewers on monday he
was a top of the zone majority of time
with the four seamer averaging out 94.
swinging a mess he struck him out good
start for vince velasquez
shut down inning to begin the game
tonight here is kutch who grounded out
his first time up outfield he's him
slightly to pull
and he lines it out toward right center
field that's going to drop in for a base
hit
poche is able to handle it miller scores
easily
and going to third base and holding
there is herrera it's an rbi single for
mccutchen
he's now hitting five straight and the
philly's leading three nothing dansby
swanson is uh dangerous at least he
seems to be against the phillies he's on
deck
nobody on and ball four
back-to-back walks for velasquez
their runners on first and second
[Music]
and a swag in a foul tip he threw it 94
miles an hour second strikeout for
velasquez
runners lead off first and second three
balls two strikes
check this swing did he go yes he did
and he knew it three strikeouts for
velasquez two big ones after walking two
hitters
line drive back towards the middle and
it's caught by segura who was there he
got it right off the hands a little
humpback line drive vince velasquez
works around the two straight walks to
open the inning
two strikeouts to this point for ian
anderson is 2-2 on the way to harper's
harper down on strikes fastball got him
bertie
sling that one around the horn and one
down here in the third inning
there's the 2-2 pitch and he came back
to get balm swinging to miss
handful of change-ups in that sequence
and earns his fourth strikeout so the
fastball has been just wild enough the
change-up has been just effective enough
braves haven't done anything yet to
velasquez big shift for ozzie and the
payoff
is slashed down the left-field line
long-run mccutcheon still going still
going in the corner that's a fair ball
ozzie's on his way to second and now
he's on his way to third mccutcheon had
trouble in the corner i'll be his head
first slide into third
hunter wendelstep was seeing what
happened to mccutcheon in the corner we
lost sight of the ball
let's see what happened
hit him right in the arm while i think
mccutcher was in fairground and
that hurt
save your no hitter alerts for some
other game
i'm sure there will be one either today
or tomorrow
ground ball shortstop gregorius has it
flips to second inning is over and again
velasquez
allows two base runners just like he did
in the second but works out of the jab
andrew mccutchen will lead off for the
fills we go to the top of the fifth
and he lines it out to left center field
i guess the wrist is fine
pasha backhands it mccutchen takes a big
turn that's his second hit there's gene
seguro the batter and the one-two pitch
on the way ground ball back up the
middle it hits the second base bag it
bounces into center field cuts around
second he's on his way to third and
they're on the corners with nobody out
after another hit for gene segura well
here's a rare opportunity for harper not
only with runners on base but with the a
man in scoring position
back to the mound he's going to fire to
second for one quick turn first is in
time and double play anderson looked
mccutcheon back he never broke toward
the plate and two long throws he's still
at third now with two out that's one of
those plays right there chip if the
braves come back and win this game you
might look to that right there because
that could have been the part where the
game was broken wide open two outs for
rio muto let's see what ian has in store
with another 3-2 he got him what a job
first and third nobody out harper a
double play real muto a strikeout the
2-2 pitch
breaking ball strike three called got
him looking vince now goes through the
order a third time and acuna
and a strike three called on the inside
corner of cunha jr can't believe it
slams his bat down slams his helmet down
speaking of big-time bats it's time for
the braves offense to do something now
braves are one for their last 27
swing and a high fly ball headed for the
bullpen herrera as far as he can go it's
another homer for freeman against philly
that snaps the longest hitless streak of
freddie's career it was all for 22. and
the grades are on the board
it's a 3-1 game boy did he need that
chip so the tying run comes to the plate
and who better to hit a fast ball than
ronald acuna jr top and that almost hit
him how close was that let's see if he
can get some payback pitch and that off
his hand helmet slam they go inside
twice this time it hits ronald on the
left hand holding his left hand and
screaming in pain and ronald is shaking
his head and holding that left hand and
he's coming out of the game and now it's
freddie freeman versus alvarado with two
on and two out in a two-run game
and a bouncer over to first base and the
inning is over phillies go to their
closer hector nearest what do we say all
the time close games late inning walks
let's see if sandoval can bring the
braves back from the brink
swing and a high five ball right center
field headed to the bump head pablo
well there's pandemonium here right now
he's done it again and the braves have
tons of life now
i'm pretty sure contreras hasn't seen
this
in his young career but here's a spot
where if he just dumped one over the
heads of the phillies infield drawn in
braves walk home happy bouncer over to
third balm's got it he's coming home and
that's the one out they'll get here
that's a good play on a good pitch
two away here in the tenth inning trying
to get this game to the eleven and the
one-two pitch swing and a miss he got
him
how about brandon kinsler coming on
and sending this game to the 11th inning
so two gone and it's up to nick maton
and this one is going to hit off the
wall deep in right center phillies have
the lead on an rbi double by nick mayton
adrianza coming up great speed down at
second base base hit should tie up the
ball game as this one chopped off the
plate didi's got it thrown to first
throw it
comes punchy he slides in safely it ties
the game right harper coming up his
fourth consecutive chance with runners
off
ground ball back toward the middle
they're coming home the throw is wide
one runs it here comes mccutcheon
nobody's covered home
he scores
the phillies take a two run lead here's
jt ramuto
shot the other way basing it to right
field knapple score seven for phillies
well faces are loaded terrace the batter
he's over five and over his last ten
what a win it is just to get the winning
run to the plate after what happened to
the top of the inning line drive left
field that's down for a hit that'll
score two streaking toward third swanson
they're gonna wave it here he comes they
miss the cutoff man here it's a double
and we're tied a bases clearing double
for contreras yeah they were going to
stop swansea at third base but that
bobble as small as it was was enough to
give confidence to ron washington to
give that green light and dansby took
off matt moore faces pache winning run
at second there's nobody out get this
man to third he shows butt lays it down
throw
late to third and safe
somehow contreras got in ahead of the
play
hey adrianza with a chance to be the
hero who'da thunk it driven to right
field that ball is down and the braves
have won it the chase is on andy
adrianza
and the braves somehow
someway
win this one in 12 what a game
you